Magnus and Hikaru just clocked in
another epic match against one another
in the Champions chess tour they put on
a clinic of precision drawing their
first two games with 98% accuracy each
in both games this sent the match to
Armageddon to ensure a decisive result
in Armageddon a draw with the black
pieces is considered a win so players
bid the amount of time they're willing
to play with in order to get draw ODS
Magnus played mind games with his bid
while precise play continued on both
sides the most important piece in this
game would end up being the clock
despite starting with less time Naru
eventually gained an advantage on the
clock but a blunder spelled a reversal
of Fortune Magnus traded into a winning
endgame of Bishop versus knight and an
extra Pawn forcing Hikaru to take too
much time to think since Armageddon
games have no increment Naru was almost
pre-moving IRL Magnus maintained the
pressure and eventually won giving him a
perfect score in the tournament so far